we are all one decision away from
changing our lives forever and a lot of
us don't even know it and the difference
between the decisions you make today and
the ones that you made last year if
they've gotten you to where you are
right now they were not good decisions
and so if we want to have more power in
our lives we have to first understand
what power is and second how to unlock
it through the actions and decisions
that we make and if you have a company
or a business or a job where you need to
influence other people or you need to
get people to say yes or you need people
to make decisions or most importantly
make decisions for yourself that are
going to change your life for the better
then we have to understand what the
topic means if you don't know who i am
my name is austral mostly i own
acquisition.com and 10 years ago i was
sleeping on a gym floor and 10 years
later i am now in my mom's basement that
is how much better my life getting this
is actually penthouse and i like to work
in a closet because i like having the
quiet and not having distractions but
uh my life has gone significantly better
uh and i recently spoke at coaching con
and they wanted me to talk about this
specific topic because there was a
series of events and decisions that made
massive differences in my life and i
broke them down and after i gave the
speech and got off stage i had hundreds
of people who messaged me saying that
that uh speech was one of the things
that made them take huge strides in
their life and honestly made them more
powerful and that is all i want for you
mostly nation is to become more and more
powerful so that we can all make the
world a better place all right so enjoy
the presentation and i'll see you guys
the other side it's just great to be
here so thank you guys so much
i promise that i will do my absolute
best
to give you a high return on your
attention uh because it's the most
valuable thing you guys have i just want
to thank you for investing here with me
today so
that being said uh the reason i went up
with gold diggers because we all know
who's the real person who makes the
money in the family um
and so i i picked right that's by the
way the best passive income strategy in
existence is just to marry someone rich
um they don't talk about that one right
the uh the second thing though that i
want to talk about is uh
is
power and i think that actually before i
get into that who here
wants to be powerful
awesome and that's not everybody raised
their hand which is interesting
and i think i find it interesting
because i ask that question sometimes
and in an audience sometimes it's easier
to remain anonymous but one-on-one when
you stare at someone's eyes you're like
do you want to be powerful a lot of
people shrink away from that and i think
it's because at least me when i was
coming up i had negative associations
with the word to me power was like the
emperor in uh star wars you know the
lightning old fingers and everybody
and so to me that was like power but i
saw it as a negative thing
and i feel like as i developed i started
to learn that power is neutral
you can be incredibly powerful and bad
incredibly powerful and good and so the
idea is if we can harness power then it
amplifies who we are
and if we're shitty people then we're
very very shitty people and we're very
good we're very very good and so i hope
that all of us aspire to have more power
in our lives and that is the underlying
theme of the presentation i'm gonna talk
to you guys about today
so
decision making
who's so excited about decision making
well i'll give you the sub headline
which is selling with logic to make lots
of money
and
i think there are different selling
styles when i because i've trained a lot
of sales teams we've built a lot of
sales teams sold a lot of different
industries now
people sell differently
who here would consider themselves like
an emotional seller like you get like
emotionally invested in the prospect you
get them to cry anybody like that i'm
saying cool who here is somebody who is
uh is more of a like i'm not going to
let you leave
type so you know who you are just raise
your hand i am that way too sometimes
all right just me fair enough um and
then the third is kind of logical
selling which is like let's just talk
through this
and if it makes sense let's do it if it
doesn't no worries between those three
types i i tend to actually be more of a
logical seller in general and
i've gotten a lot of a claim rightfully
or not that was wild um
sorry
i actually have a fear of birds um
so
this was about to be a very short
presentation
and so
and so a lot of the a lot of my like
success using logic and sales has given
me a lot of acclaim and this is the
first presentation that i've put
together so this is just for you guys
this is a brand new presentation because
i've been thinking about
like reverse engineering what are the
things what are the frameworks we think
about
to get to yes right and the yes that i
want from somebody is not a yes i'm
going to buy
but yes i'm going to decide and i think
if you can delineate that for yourself
too it takes a little bit of the
pressure off selling because my goal is
to give this person power
and you have to understand what power is
in order to give it right who here knows
the definition of power
go for it
i love that thought to existence is what
he said
which is actually a really favorite way
so the dictionary definition
is the ability to influence or direct
events or people that's the dictionary
definition but i love how you said it
because as i see omnipotence so god or a
god figure would be as they think it
appears
so the the distance between thoughts and
reality are ins there's there is no
distance right that would be an
omnipotent being if he thinks the world
the world exists right and so as we take
steps towards that as the ideal we
become more powerful and if we can do
that for our prospects we can allow them
to step into the person they want to be
and make a decision to own their [ __ ]
one way or another does that make sense
cool all right so let's rock
so this will either be
the best presentation on sales you've
ever heard
the worst presentation on sales you've
ever heard
or somewhere in between that is a
promise
all right
and so i thought it would make sense to
start with this we have a high this is
charlie munger who's probably like my
number one hero in this season of my
life
we have a high moral responsibility to
be rational and i think that getting
someone to rationally decide is
important because emotional buyers
oftentimes get excited they'll buy and
then who's had somebody who calls him
two days later is like i don't know why
anybody raise your hand just so you know
you're not alone okay and what happens
is it's just like dating i think layla
talked about it yesterday
if you have a rational foundation for a
relationship or a decision when the
emotions fade the logic will continue
and so it's good to answer both sides of
the decision-making process the
short-term side is the emotion that gets
you to decrease your action threshold
and take a step right but the logic is
what makes it stick and actually makes a
great customer all right and so
for me and i think that the further
along you get in business and the higher
up you get in business the more you'll
see people who tend to make more logical
decisions more logic first decisions and
fewer and fewer emotional decisions all
right
so
what does being a rational sorry what
does rational logical have to do with
selling
well
you have logical buyers and you have
emotional buyers in general right
most people sit on this continuum one
way or the other
and
emotionally
people want to believe you people want
to buy
you must help their logical brains
justify the decision that they already
want to make
think about it that way they want to buy
from you you have to help them all right
so
who here identifies actually i'll skip
through this emotional logical you're
probably in between anybody in between
these two anyone all right then you'll
love this
so before we get started
i thought
i would give you a few beliefs about
selling that have served me very well
throughout the years
number one
people want to believe you they want to
buy you must help their logical blames
brains justify the decision two
selling happens before you ask
for the sale
closing happens after so you're selling
for a lot longer period of time but the
moment you kind of like take your pants
off and you're like this is what it is
that's when you're closing
right
you have now solicited
now you close
three it's easier to handle obstacles
than objections
i'll get to what the difference between
those are in a second
that being said
expect and plan for no
it is not failure it is expected so stop
being surprised it's one of the first
things we talk new sales guys into is
expect no that's not like that's a part
of this
if they already were going to say yes
then you are not necessary
no is the job right if they could make
the decision on their own
they would just send you the money right
the reason they're struggling is because
they can't and they need your help which
is why sales is actually the first step
in coaching and i see sales as power
if you can have the ability
to direct or influence others that is
power
and i feel like it should be made much
cooler than i feel like it is five if
you didn't get a gasp from a price tag
you didn't go high enough
this is another belief so for those who
are afraid to raise your price if you're
not getting gasps you're not going high
enough
straight up
and when you do it that way you can
always walk down and have a beautiful
price anchor
right when you say a hundred thousand
dollars first a grand feels like a
rounding error it's true but when i say
ten dollars first like i'm saying right
now ten dollars and i say a thousand
sounds way [ __ ] bigger doesn't it
so you gotta get the gas and you gotta
train your guys if you have a team
they have to be comfortable with no and
they have to be comfortable with the
gasp they gotta go for the gasp and be
like dude you should have heard the gasp
on this one right
there we go seven
selling properly is the first step
becoming a coach right your first
impressions the expeditions you set
dictate the relationship how you sell
the fact that use logic in the sale will
set you up for success and your client
for success in the long run eight
selling is helping prospects make
decisions out themselves like you are
helping them help themselves that's
where the power comes from you are not
helping them you're helping them help
them
see the difference it's nuanced but it's
real nine keep the prospect
not the sale as the priority
it's not about us the more you can
vanish
in the sale and
and magnify them
the better your selling conversations
will go because it's not about us
they don't care about you they only care
about them and they will talk about
themselves as long as they'll let them
this is a really important one
especially when you start to getting
into closing
seek to understand
not to argue
and the way that i train our sales teams
around this is
childlike curiosity
so when someone says when someone
objects to something
it's like huh that's so weird i wouldn't
have thought that tell me more about
that right and you get to be able to
maintain that childlike curiosity the
same way they train fighters to not
breathe too much during a fight
through exposure the more you more times
you get into these uncomfortable high
stakes closing scenarios the less weird
and high stakes they become because they
become what you do every day and the
good thing is you get to have this
conversation hundreds and thousands of
times and they only get to have it once
so you [ __ ] better be better at it
than them
closing is a dance not a fight
it's seduction
not rape
i mean i'm being super serious about
this
the goal is not to beat them into
submission the goal is to
sell from your back foot
it's like i'm good i want to help you
help you and if that means not doing
this then i [ __ ] love it i'm with you
i'm on your team
and i'll give you a bullet around that
in a second
selling is a transference of belief over
a bridge of trust therefore there are
two things that are required
you must believe so that you can
transfer it and you must have trust to
make the transfer because if you truly
believe in a lot of times you st anyone
been on a hot streak when they're
selling anyone
anyone who just had their hand up ever
been on a cold streak
most times you go from hot to cold not
because you forgot how to sell because
you stop believing in why you're selling
you have the same skills as you did the
day before
but sometimes you get a text you get an
email you get a pain in the ass customer
you ask for a refund whatever the hell
it is right and then you question
yourself
and so that bridge might have been
created but there was nothing to walk
across it because your cup wasn't full
and so that's why especially it's you in
the beginning but your teams over time
the process of filling
conviction
is one of the easiest and best ways to
increase someone's closing percentage
better than any of the training in the
world
if you get someone to believe they will
sell the right way because they're doing
it not to make the deal because they
want to help the other person 16. you
can only build trust if you generally
want to help and humans are
exceptionally good at sniffing out
intention it's a survival mechanism you
have to know if someone's trying to
double cross you we're very good at
smelling it out
and the reason a lot of you guys can't
close is because you only care about
closing
belief and trust are a continuum not
binaries so it's not you believe or
don't believe it's not they trust you or
don't trust you but how much do they
trust you
how much do you believe how deeply do
you believe because anyone ever been
around somebody who just believes balls
to bone something that you think is
batshit crazy
like i mean all the way
so much so that you start to question
what you believe
that's what real conviction does
18 closers ask hard questions and it's
because you genuinely care
that's why you do it it's why we're here
who here wants to impact thousands of
lives and help people
then you got to [ __ ] ask hard
questions because it's the only thing
that's going to actually pierce
someone's heart and actually get the
transformation to happen if you can't
make if you cannot have transformational
conversations you cannot coach
and this is the first step
the person who cares the most about the
prospect wins the sale
that includes them
so if you care more about their
well-being than they do you will win
and if you are more convicted
they will question their own excuses
because you are so certain
a little little nugget for you report
all your sales
by the way because when you do get on
that hot streak right you get on that
hot streak and then you get cold again
watch your hot streak
see where you pause what jokes you made
when you asked for the sale when you did
it how you overcame it and it'll get you
back in the flow much faster than trying
to question yourself what i do what i do
always report all your sales it's also
the easiest way to train new people
and then lastly 21
power is the ability to direct or
influence people
if you want to be powerful
you must understand this skill
and that's what we're going to talk
about cool
awesome
when does selling happen does it happen
when they're a lead does it happen when
we're qualifying them
does it happen when we solicit the sale
does it happen when we close the sale
when does the selling happen
all the time the entire time selling is
happening
but what are we going to talk about
today
just this
just closing everything you have to do
after
asking someone to buy
why are we doing that rather than the
entire process beyond the fact that we'd
be here all day
the other reason and i love this
is that closing has one of the highest
predictors of success in business
and here's an analogy for it
everyone familiar with the nfl
great
so here's an insane statistic
the top five red zone offenses in the
league
now last five years
made the playoffs 90 of the time here's
why this is interesting and crazy
there's a million other stats they could
have horrible defenses they could have
terrible coaching they could have a
terrible whatever it is right they could
have all these things that are wrong
with their they could have terrible
special teams whatever
but just this one set
if they're in the red zone
they [ __ ] close
and i can tell you if you have this
ability if you have the skill it will
make up for a tremendous amount of
deficiencies in other areas of your life
and business and it will buy you time to
learn those
but if you can't close it's very
difficult to grow in business especially
in the beginning because it's probably
you that's why we're talking about
closing
why is this important from a money
getting perspective
well first off if you have 100 people
walk in the door
10
are never going to buy just accept that
right problem is you don't know which 10
it is
but ten percent ever gonna buy ten
percent are always gonna buy you just
gotta not [ __ ] it up
and most of you guys these are the only
sales you're getting they're like well i
already i'm already here my friend told
me about you i have my credit card out
and some of you are like well you know
let's make sure you're like just shut
the [ __ ] just take the card you know
what i mean like shut up right that's
like hey my friend's so awesome you got
to meet him and she's like oh my god
he's great and then the guy starts
talking and she's like just kidding you
know like
terrible right but this is what we fight
for this is what we train and if you
want to make a big impact
that's what we're fighting for it's the
middle 80.
why this presentation will make you
money if after this presentation you
just have one more bullet one more play
in your arsenal to close where i get you
one more deal a month i'll feel like my
job was done all right
and hopefully if you just do that it'll
pay for your entire weekend all right
that's my goal for the president that
everything that you guys have done for
this whole weekend is paid for is that
cool fair outcome
all right
this is one of my favorite sayings
you're only one decision away from
changing your life forever
and whenever i feel overwhelmed or i
feel like i'm decreasing like i feel
powerless i feel like i have less power
than i want to have i always say this to
myself because it's like
i can take one decision and change
[ __ ] everything
you know i mean like i can i can drink a
bottle of jack get in the car i can
change everything with one decision
right i can make a step to to invest in
something i can buy something i can
invest in myself i can i can have a
terrible conversation with an amazing
conversation with layla but just one
decision and that's always given me
power but the thing is is that instead
of changing our lives
we blame when i say blame i want you to
think give power to
sources outside of our control
and this is what you and this is what
your prospects and your customers are
doing
and this is why so many people are weak
and powerless
and so we're going to do a fun activity
today because i want you to be involved
so you can learn it we're going to do
this so that one you can help decisions
to help yourself with whatever decisions
you're facing two you can use these
frameworks to help prospects help
themselves
and the three become more powerful
so but rather than keep this
hypothetical i need you to visualize the
decision that you need to make all right
you do that for me
fantastic and this is why i want you to
actually think through a decision
together
because this is a statement from
confucius i hear and i forget
i see and i remember
i do and i understand so my goal here
isn't for you to take screenshots of
every picture
of every slide that's not my point here
because the thing is is when you do that
and you kind of i mean this is why i do
it i take pictures so that i don't have
to remember it but i don't want you to
remember it i want you to understand it
if you understand it you won't have to
go back to your notes because let's be
real half the time you're not even open
these notes up again you're here now
with me try and understand if you do
that it can change your life because
what we're going to do is not going to
be some scripts that you have to
understand but the logic behind the
arguments that people will give you as
to why they are not choosing to become
more powerful and if you can unlock that
you people will feel more powerful
talking to you and they will want to buy
from me because of the feeling they have
does that make sense and so that's when
you're using logic to create an emotion
so here here's an easy one for you
anyone here presented with the decision
last 24 hours
yes great fantastic so who thinks the
decision could change your life for the
better
great for the worse who knows all right
let's go so here's my goal i want to
show you as though you were prospects
how to think through a decision and help
others using these frameworks right what
you want what you don't want maximize
the left minimize the right so here's
what this is translated to
if you decide to buy the offer you feel
more certain about your decision decided
not to buy the offer you feel [ __ ]
certain about the decision and if you're
undecided you make a [ __ ] decision
all right and you feel good that it's
the one that has the highest likelihood
of getting you closer to where you want
to go and this is what we have to walk
through with our prospects
when you're looking at them you have to
be like i don't want you to buy
i want you to decide for you not for me
i'll be the same either way right you're
like i'm going to be ripping in shape
it's not going to change me right like
that's not going to change but like it
will change for you right
so quick note on sales ethics and then
we'll dive in helping someone make a
decision to help themselves does not
mean buying from me that's a reiteration
you have to keep their goals at the
center of the decision and you should be
happy
i mean this because if you can shift
this truly if you can be happy when
someone decides to own the power and not
work with you then the pressure around
sales disappears it evaporates there's
no stake the stake is did i help them
does that make sense and that means that
you can win every sale because you
change the metric you're measuring
yourself by that's the superpower
like and that's where you do make the
most sales because you don't care about
the sale because you care about the
person and the people pay the people who
pay the most attention so i call it
paying attention they pay for it they
pay for you to pay attention rather than
talking about yourself
right because they don't care about you
because they're thinking about 100 other
things and this is why most importantly
make high-stakes decisions to help your
prospects in order to best serve them
okay
so i told you earlier i was going to
talk about the difference between
obstacles and objections a couple you
guys raised your hands
but the differences
i'm not gonna ask i'll tell you what it
is obstacle is a thing that blocks one's
way or prevents or hinders progress
when you disagree with them
that is an obstacle this happens before
you solicit the sale
someone says some [ __ ] before we
even get to the sale that's an obstacle
a simple example i hear all the time hey
why'd you hop on the call today hey
why'd you walk in the gym today whatever
it is right
them i just wanted to find out a little
bit more about the program first 10
seconds
obstacle
you're not here to find out more about
the program your because you're fat
but they got to say it
so you're like oh so you're finding out
like do you do this all the time do you
go to lots of different programs to find
out information or is there a problem
you're trying to solve
they're like
oh well you know i'm trying to lose
weight like oh god so you're not just
hopping on 100 calls a day because i was
like that would be a very weird
existence right you just hop on for
information all day
right fantastic
i've had this conversation before right
so it's an obstacle right and the thing
is it's easy to confront and destroy
obstacles before you ask for the sale
once you've asked for the sale
you switch to objections
objections is when they disagree with
you
so it's much easier to be on the other
side disagreeing and helping them break
their beliefs before the stake has been
presented
after after the after you're in the red
zone it's all closing it's all objection
overcomes right example that's like i
don't want to buy right now and you're
like totally understand what are the
main criteria thinking through
which is always funny because people are
like i need to think about it i've never
had someone like leave because they need
to think about it i'm like cool what are
you thinking about
they're like oh i'm still here
right
so learning how to talk through these
high stakes decisions with yourself or
others is the purpose of presentation
and as a result you'll become more
powerful okay so before i dive into
these each of these arguments i have to
make this one statement that the person
must really want the goal
and believe three things
one
which we'll get to there we go the
product will get you the goal comma the
way they want to get there and i learned
that second half the hard way because we
found out in gym launch that people
would say no sometimes to buying
memberships right or buying challenges
or whatever but when we offered them the
ability to come back the next day help
them for free
we'd sell them 400 of supplements and
they just said no to 100 down
service thing
and like what the [ __ ] it's because
they want to lose weight
but they want to lose weight their way
and so that's when i started learning
like oh
not only do we have to make sure that
they want the goal
and they believe that the product's
going to get them there that has to get
them there the way they want to get
there this gives you ammo for the
questions that you're going to ask just
make sense
okay
the second thing is that you and others
will support them like are you telling
me the truth is this really what's going
to happen will other people around me
support this decision
and the third
is that it will work for them and not
just everyone else
sure
i've seen the people who step on the
stage
but they're different than me
i'm a snowflake i have metabolic thyroid
ketosis right
whatever i have zero influenza allerger
whatever you know what i mean like i
have no following is itis right whatever
it is right whatever [ __ ] you tell
yourself
and what you have to do in this
situation is you have to provide proof
so that it'd be more unreasonable not to
believe than to believe and this is a
logical close this is not a this is not
an emotional close
this is when you look at someone and say
how many people would you need to see
for it to be more unreasonable for you
not to believe than to believe
at what point is it 10
is it 50
well here's a thousand
tell me when to stop
okay okay okay great so that's not the
real reason
and then you can confront the real [ __ ]
all right so otherwise if they're not
sure of those things if they don't
actually want to lose weight if you
don't actually want to make money
doing online fitness
then it doesn't matter what jason says
you don't want to make money doing all
my fitness you're not going to buy right
if you do want to make money doing
online fitness then you go down you go
down the track the train tracks that
make sense
okay again this is why you expect no at
first because if people could make the
decision they would have already made it
all right now to the main course
richard feynman besides charlie one of
my favorite thinkers of all time he was
like the second guy on uh the atom bomb
sounds negative brilliant teacher he's
known for this
understand don't memorize learn
principles not formulas and that's what
the rest of this presentation is about
is the principles behind overcoming
these distortions that people have and
so this is me asking you for your own
sake don't take pictures of the slides
it's because all the stuff's gonna be in
the recordings but you are here now so
be here now so you can understand it
okay
so there are three sources this is a
huge breakthrough for me so i'm going to
share it with you the first time shared
a life there are three sources that we
cast our power to okay and it took me a
very long time to get through this
because i looked at grant and he had his
you know you got stall decision maker
money then you talked to barry who owns
sage she's like you got
time fit
uh money
fear shame right those are hers and then
jordan belfort's got his and so
everybody's got like these are the only
overcomes right i was like there has to
be an actual truth here like there has
to be something that's true that's
unquestioned
and so trying to figure this out i
actually went back to dr albert ellis
anybody who knew he is
no one great um who here knows what
cognitive behavioral therapy is cbt
he invented it
smart dude
and so what he noticed is that he
originally had 11 distortions of reality
then he dropped it to nine then a seven
and they came with three and the three
stuck and the three are what i'm about
to share with you and you're like why is
he talking about this about sales
because the objections that people offer
you where they cast their power to are
distortions of reality
they are the things we use to upset
ourselves
these are the three
circumstances and this is the irrational
statement that people make
i must get what i want when i want it i
must not get what i don't want if i
don't get what i want i can't stand it
that's when people blame their emotional
disturbances on
emotional services on circumstances
two
others
other people must treat me fairly and
kindly and if i if they don't they are
no good and deserve to be condemned and
punished
it's like your animal brain right
three
self i must do well or else i am no good
these are the three core distortions
that upset people
this is like mental illness right
and so i'm not saying anyone has mental
illness if they don't agree with you
it's more so that these are distortions
that are not real and if you can
understand not memorize if you can
understand this then you can have these
high-stakes conversations understanding
exactly which distortion they're
suffering from and i'll show you how to
overcome them okay
and so i like to consider like the onion
of blame people this is like one of the
bigger breakthroughs i had they start
with the outside they blame
circumstances
time money other [ __ ] and then the step
next to that they start to blame other
people my spouse my kids my employees
and then finally they say like it's me
it's my fault
and so you might have to overcome
multiple layers as you peel back
and based on the objection they give you
you can know where you're at you know
how close you are if someone just says i
have to think about that you're like
great i'm talking the person who's in
power and the decision maker and i just
need to get them to say yes
if they're like i don't have
they're casting the power away and some
of you guys are probably casting your
power away on decisions you need to make
which is why i'm making this
presentation
even though that these are the things
that distort people's realities because
you're like no one's ever said
circumstances are getting in my way
right like no one says
they manifest in five ways that i want
to equip you to deal with all right
for yourself and others so these are the
five most common excuses scapegoats that
people use
for circle and if you find other ones
these are the biggest buckets because i
didn't want to have 100 things here but
the big three buckets are circumstances
others itself right but they manifest
with time in multiple ways and i'll show
you how value price money etc
fit i'm a special snowflake others which
is i don't have the authority to make
the decision
and then finally self which is
what if i just don't make the decision
let some let life make it for me right
avoidance stall
you go from surface level to core and as
a side note
you should never get stuck on the stuff
near the top
and ideally you should really never get
stuck anywhere on this equation if the
person wants what you have
and you truly believe in what you have
to help them
and i mean that like if you understand
this thoroughly you can walk someone
towards helping themselves
okay this is what they look like or this
is what they sound like in reality
not a good not a good time right now i'm
really busy right that's time
can't afford it too expensive
fit not sure if it's for me i hate
broccoli i can't do a plan with broccoli
right
i can't do a plan where i have to dm
people every day it's against my brand
i'm poor but it's against my bread right
authority
have to talk to my partner spouse i have
to talk to somebody who has more power
than me it's funny because when you
start thinking this way it sounds silly
and then avoidance i need to think about
it clearly let's think about it now all
right and so i told you i want you to
think about the principles behind these
things not memorize
you've got circumstances you've got
other people and you have yourself and
we drill down
so quick test who here is physically in
the room raise your set wonderful arms
are working we're rocking
so here's my ask raise your hand if you
or your prospects present with this
distortion
so who here is a time person i'm busy
it's not a good time maybe in the future
anyone deal with these
sometimes it's yourself totally so i'm
also going to tell you a secret about
this i think the reason i got pretty
decent at
logical arguments is because i am
inherently skeptical and i will paralyze
myself from not doing anything unless i
have really sound reasons to do it and i
realized that i couldn't move forward
and make any progress in my life until i
had these frameworks to think through
these hard decisions through so i could
start taking steps to where where i
wanted to go
it took me years to get there and so
hopefully i can give you some keys that
help me unlock my own head to get out my
own [ __ ] way so that you can too and
help your clients all right
so the way i think about time and
there's a lot of overcomes for all of
these things what i tried to do is bunch
the three biggest ones that i like to
use most frequently and if i uh veer
from like the the bullets on the screen
it's because i'm riffing with you and
i'd rather just kind of stay in the flow
is that cool okay fantastic so when
you're overcoming this one
each of these is kind of a specific
angle that you're attacking it from
so macro is like um this is a busy
season for me i've got lots of stuff
going on right
micro is like i don't have any time in
my day so you're one person saying i've
got lots of [ __ ] going on one person's
like i can't find the time it's
different sounds subtle but it's both
about time but in different ways all
right and then the the last one is well
when when i have time i'll start
right whichever one is this [ __ ]
horseshit but whatever okay so
as always we never disagree with
prospects because you're not in a fight
totally get it totally understand do you
think
like do you want this to be something
that lasts for the long term
right it's a question you're like yeah
do you think that you're going to be
busy again in the future
well yeah
so you want this to last in the long run
and you do think you're going to be busy
again in the future well then don't you
think it'd be best to start now when you
are busy because if you learn how to do
it when you're busy you'll be able to do
it forever if you can only learn it
during a perfect circumstance then
you're going to fall off when it gets
busy again and isn't that the time you'd
want to have the most support it goes
for you guys too
that's just number one we got so many
lore
right
and so
when you knock that out the goal is that
the person says well [ __ ] that's not a
good reason you take one step
towards the truth
so when you're thinking about it's not
like oh i've got to overcome this one
thing and then they'll buy
you got to keep peeling and if you have
this framework you understand the
direction you're going in and you can
start listening for the oh they're
talking about themselves now i've gotten
two layers deeper right so that's
seasonal
micro you can't tell someone in a sale
hey take out your phone take out your
hours by week pull it up oh look 22
hours on social media this week you've
got time so you say it differently you
say you know what i had the same issue
and i used to complain all the time
about like how i didn't have time to to
be successful and do things i needed to
do and my wife got so sick and tired of
me saying this she pulled my phone out
and she was like look i guess i just
found your time didn't i i was like oh
[ __ ] and you can say it that way and
then a prospect feels better does
anybody here feel like they don't have
time right
and
the first thing that any program is
going to do if it's a good program is
going to cut out the 90 of the [ __ ] that
you are doing which is causing you to
feel overwhelmed which is probably the
real reason you feel like you don't have
time jeff bezos at the same time you do
right
it's just
what are the things that you're doing
that he's not
it's not about adding [ __ ] to your plate
it's about removing stuff that's not
working because clearly everything
you're doing that's filling your time is
not making you more money so you're
doing the wrong [ __ ]
so there's gonna be plenty of time
because all the stuff you're doing now
is not working
right
it sounds simple but that's the reason
right so we want macro grow
when then
hey
in the future
when i've got time i'll totally sign up
for your program right anyone heard this
one
anyone say this one
right
and again you wanna you wanna empathize
you don't say like ah that's [ __ ]
you say totally understand that's i was
stuck like this for years if you can
step in their shoes you're not attacking
them you actually go from the inside out
you step into their self and then you
walk them through the epiphany that you
experienced
and it doesn't feel judgmental it feels
helpful that make sense
i used to feel the same way right and
i found this out actually from jason
fladley and he was when he told me this
it's a it's a logical fallacy it's
called the one then fallacy which is why
it's how i remember it
and the one then fallacy simply states
when i have x then i will do y but it
flips sequence
so it's like when i get better i will go
to the hospital
sorry there's just so many like
hilarious ones about like money and
stuff like i will start saving money
once i'm rich like
all right the thing is is that we do
this
right we do this
i'll pay for the program that'll make me
more money when i have more money
that's the point of the program i'll pay
for the program that'll help me get a
six-pack once i have a six-pack
once i have more time which the
program's gonna help me you know i'm
saying like it's just it doesn't make
it's a fallacy and so what that means is
it's a distortion
it's not real
and so the goal of having these
high-stakes conversations is simply
showing people we're not attacking
we're just walking them through and be
like do you realize that this is holding
you back
and i know this better than anyone
because i'm a skeptical [ __ ] the
reason i can do all these logical things
is because i'm the first person i'd
overcome
right
and you might be too
so
once we attack time
from these three angles depends which
one they present with if they present
with one and then move to the next you
can knock all three out you'll probably
find some that that make the most sense
to you but the thing here is it's not
about memorization you just got to get
it macro you're always going to be busy
won't you want the most help when you
are busy so they can stick forever yes
time my wife showed me my phone
turns out i got [ __ ] time but the
reality is it's not about what i am
doing it's about the stuff i got to stop
doing and that's what i help you with
right
this isn't scripting this is just
understanding it right and then when
then it's a fallacy it's a distortion
it's not real and then just use two
crazy examples like once i have money
then i'll save money when i'm rich right
it's just like ridiculous okay so what
do we do
one reason down and we're getting closer
to the core
right
right
so who here is somebody who's like i
can't afford it it's too expensive or
has heard this from a prospect
i was like i better see everybody's
hands
especially if you're selling high ticket
which hopefully you get a gasp so these
are the four frameworks that i think
through there's a million like money
closes but these are the ones that i
like the most
and that that to me resonate the best
right and so why a lot is good is kind
of like my my first one here and so the
reason that if someone gasps or think
that this is a lot of money you just ask
them is this a lot of money to you and
they're gonna say yeah if they say no
then you're like awesome buy it and if
they say yes
right
and if they say yes
then you're like that's the exact reason
why you're going to be successful
because there's other people who buy
this thing and you know what they're not
all in on it but the question is do you
want to draw the lawn in the sand and go
all in do you want to step over the line
and be the person you want to be
because i can tell you that this
is not about whether this works not i've
already proven that the question is
whether you work or not and so if you
put more on the line
then you have a higher likelihood of
being successful so you should be the
last person to be worried about this i'm
more excited because the best stories
are always coming from people like you
in your exact situation so don't let
that be a reason not to do it that
should be the reason to do it
so the next one is like why is this not
a lot so first is
the fact that it's a lot for you is good
it means you're going to try hard
the second was like well it's a lot in
terms of absolute amount but relative
amount it's very little right because if
all this does
is add ten thousand dollars a month to
your income
is it worth it if all this does is get
you into a bikini
is it worth it
yeah
and so then what happens and the reason
that this is a stepping process right is
that we're we're just taking these
objections out of the way so we can get
the person to confront reality not a
distortion they've created because the
reality is the thing they're afraid of
and so what happens is when they say
yeah
if it did that it would be worth it
right the problem is they don't believe
you
right
and so it's like great then it's not
about the price
it's about whether you believe me so you
can sidestep it does that make sense
we're taking a step closer
and then obviously you can use a
comparison you know depending on what
you're selling if you can price anchor
with like well here they don't have a
four-year degree for doing online
fitness
that's why the alternative education
industry exists and it's because the
formal education has failed most of us
right anybody graduated here with a
four-year degree
anyone immediately be able to use that
for your degree to get leads make sales
no
me neither
right and what's crazy is that some of
these degrees are 50 100 200 000
and take four years
when you've got something that can help
you make
make that entire amount of money in half
the time right for a tenth of the price
when you think about it like that frame
it's actually a great deal does that
make sense
so you just frame it you have to give
context all right so number one
is the fact that it's a lot for you is
good it means you're actually going to
try number two is if it does what we say
it's going to do
the value is there so that's not
actually what you're opposed to which
then we can take the next step all right
number three is what's money good for
anyways this is actually one of my
favorite lines of reasoning
for a variety of reasons and i'll get to
it
when you're looking at a prospect or
looking at yourself
you're going to spend this money either
way over the next 12 months
you're going to spend it right and in
fact
not only are you going to spend it
you're going to buy the program the
question is whether you're going to pay
for it money or pay for it in time and
so like you can learn every single
lesson that's in this program whether
it's losing weight
you know
getting leads selling online whatever it
is right you're going to learn these
lessons but do you want it to take
12 weeks
or 12 years
and the question is are you going to be
able to live a thousand lifetimes
because of the thousand people that
we've helped just like you and gathered
all those lessons and put them together
so you don't have to do the trial and
error for that entire period of time so
the question is not whether you're going
to buy it or not it's just how do you
want to pay
and so for me this is a personal note
and i'll probably say it at the end but
like
the reason it'll move quickly through
life is that i will buy other people's
mistakes because it's just it's the only
way you can buy time
in this life is to buy the knowledge to
take less time from other people who
have taken their time and like if you
think about human civilization in
general edison took however long to make
a light bulb and then we just bought the
lesson from him and now we have light
bulbs right and the next guy figures out
the next thing and then we just buy the
lesson from him and that's how we have
to move faster so you're going to spend
the money either way the question is 12
months from now is it going to be on
[ __ ] that didn't get you anywhere or
stuff that is going to get you somewhere
and no matter what
you're buying you're buying the program
you're just gonna pay time you're gonna
pay with money
and if we're being real you've probably
been paying for time the last six years
how's that working for you do you want
to do more of that
this is also this is a this is a classic
one it's a very easy one to remember
but like
who here knows the difference between
a self-made billionaire when they had
nothing
and where you're at right now if you
have nothing
zero they both you're both broke
they were broke you're broke whatever it
is that's where you're at right now
the only difference is that that proves
that if they were successful
it wasn't about the resources they had
it's about how resourceful they were
so i'll tell you a quick story about
this
so anyone here read uh shoe dog
right the story of nike so in the story
he talks about how he was
about to lose everything multiple times
it's a crazy story
and
this time it was like it was it was
going to go down like it wasn't going to
happen and he needed a tremendous amount
of money and he just didn't have it he'd
extend all his credit lines the banks
wouldn't do it and the next lenders they
canceled on him and the company's going
to fold because he was growing too fast
at that point he could have just given
up and said there's nothing i can do i
backs out all my cards i maxed it on my
banks there's literally nothing i can do
and his people already worked for free
they're like we can't do this anymore
he went to his vendors
and said you need to pay my payroll for
me
he went to his vendors
anybody use like landing page software
anyone uh anyone use something from a
vendor right it's like going to that guy
like going to your videographer me like
listen you gotta pay payroll for me this
uh
this month because otherwise i'm not
gonna be able to keep doing business
with you because i'll be out of business
resourceful
not resources
and the reason this is so important is
because when you have nothing it's the
easiest excuse to give yourself
because you're like well i have nothing
that's why i can't
it's like of course but every self-made
millionaire and every self-made
billionaire was self-made
and they started with nothing which puts
them the exact same seat you are so the
question is do you want to have power
or do you want to not have power
when you have power
you're resourceful in our resources
right
and so if we want to make these
decisions that are going to help
ourselves we need to step into that and
so when you're talking to your prospects
it's the same thing right
does that make sense
okay rocking
i mean you can drill deeper into this is
like do you think there's anyone else
who's been in your situation who's
achieved this or maybe worse than your
situation the answer is yes and if they
can why can't you right so we're taking
steps closer you guys digging this
okay cool
oh thanks okay
thanks
i wasn't sure if it was rapt attention
or sheer boredom so
we're not you feel do you feel what
progress you're making like the person
presents this is i don't have time this
thing shit's busy blah blah and you're
like no no we're gonna take one step
closer like you know what but i i don't
have the money or it's too expensive
you're like well if you don't have the
money you're gonna be successful it's
worth it right yes i understand why it's
worth it well you don't need money to
begin with
right you got to be resourceful and you
can find the money because i'll ask you
this is a fun one for business owners
who here has had an unexpected bill ever
come up
taxes
right yeah
and then all okay so everyone here is
still alive who raised their hands
who here was able to magically
pull money
out of their ass and figure out a way to
do it raise your hand
here's what's crazy
you have the ability to be resourceful
when it's for someone else
and not for you
it's because you choose to be powerful
when someone else needs it but not for
yourself
[ __ ] up right
so stop doing that
if you function
like you have to make payroll tomorrow
and like you you're back on rent you're
going to get kicked out you think
differently and if instead of paying
your landlord you're paying you because
that's what you want to do
it shifts internally because everyone's
here just proved the fact that you can
be resourceful when you choose to be
so just choose to be
so number three is it's not sure it's a
fit for me
so
besides the obvious ones which is like
i don't want to work out broccoli sucks
i i can't do a program where
where i i can't do cardio whatever the
[ __ ] right um like i said i don't want
to do dms i don't want to post on
instagram i don't want to have a
facebook group whatever right whatever
the [ __ ] is all right i'm not sure
if the vehicle is a fit for me
so
usually you can overcome the easy ones
but if someone is just really sticking
hard these are the three that i use to
shift perspective okay
so this one is new identity new
priorities
so
it's good to have cues for these things
which is like we vote with our dollars
about the things that we care about and
if you show me what someone is spending
their money and their time on i can tell
you what their future is
and i'll tell you an interesting story
so um i had somebody who was just like
you who was like you know what i don't
want to do this either and i told her
this story can i tell you it
yes
and this is what you'd say to the
prospect right so i was with layla and
we went to sephora which is a makeup
store and
i show up like this oh
i feel welcome and so we're standing
there she's doing something and i
usually stay in the corner like this
um
and i saw these two little girls they
might have been like i don't know girl
age so like 12 to 15
this like this this
and they were like giggly and so excited
and they had like the girl with the
smock came over was like helping her out
helping them out
and she was like okay this is like
eyeliner and this is lipstick and this
is whatever blush um i'm just like using
words i've heard
this is how you paint your face and the
thing is the girls were like so excited
and then they were like right before
they left she was like girls she's like
you have to remember like now that
you're getting older and you're becoming
a woman you need to start budging for
this stuff all right so you're gonna
start buying this every month all right
so like remember you got to save some
money for this so you can have it
and the girls were so excited that they
were like yes like we're becoming women
now and these are the things that women
do
it's because when you have new identity
you have new priorities
and so you've had priorities that are
aligned with your old identity right
there's the you that goes out that you
the drinks the you that does the blah
blah blah spends money on [ __ ] you
shouldn't do spends time on [ __ ] you
shouldn't be spending time on and
there's the you that you want to be
and so right now we can draw the line in
the sand and be like do you want to keep
walking down the road that you have been
walking
and if you don't
then you have to step into a new
identity and with that new identity
comes new priorities because people who
want to be rich spend money on
themselves they spend money on education
they invest in their skill sets because
i want to align my identity with the
identity of those who came before me
who've done the things i want to do
right
and just like those little girls
stepping into that identity we too must
step into the identity that we want to
be does that make sense
and so when you're talking to somebody
who's trying to lose weight and they're
like i can't afford a gym membership and
you're like girl you're spending 200
bucks on your nails
and you've got a thousand dollar outfit
on
do you think another thousand dollar
outfit would make you look better or
your high school weight
right
do you think another thousand dollar
outfit would make you look better or
being rich as [ __ ]
and i say that for those of you who are
thinking about on the money side right
like you waste my i like
some of you guys have bigger shoe
collections than like it's like fitness
like fitness people and shoes it's like
the weird like and lululemon and the you
know spandex it's like a hundreds pieces
anyways so it's like
your whole wardrobe could be
consolidated into a skill that could buy
you as many wardrobes as you want if you
chose to right
okay rock it i don't like this certain
aspect this is one of my favorite
easiest ones to hit
which is like
you got to change the change
right
what you have been doing has been
getting what you've been getting
and you got to change the change because
like i remember i would go through meal
plans with people and they'd be like
well can we change this because this is
what i eat for breakfast can we just can
we make that to breakfast
and i'm like that breakfast makes you
look like you
[Laughter]
that way you spend your first four hours
of the day makes your bank account looks
like what it does look like
oh right
right taking steps right we're getting
closer to the truth
and so the thing is is that
it's going to hurt to change because
change hurts
and you've heard this one probably from
tony robinson if you haven't
the question is whether the pain of
staying the same is greater than the
pain of change unless we just ask
someone and this is in the help part if
someone's like
the pain of staying the same is not
worse than this change it's like then
girlfriend like gain 50 more pounds and
come back you know what i mean like get
there
i mean hit rock bottom this isn't it for
you
i'm being real
some people rock bottom is 12 body fat
some people it's 500 pounds but
everyone's got one
you just got to know where yours is and
all you really got to do is just move
what rock bottom is for you which is
kind of interesting because you start
making a change here which is kind of
interesting like interesting as a
thought but
are you in enough pain is the question
you ask the person
so for those of you who are unwilling to
make a change because it feels contrary
to like i don't want to do i don't want
to seem salesy i don't want to i don't
want to help people like whatever right
like is your current situation more
painful
than the change that you will have to go
through or experience to get to where
you want to go and so the last one is
hypothetical i actually really love this
this is a great framework overall for
overcoming lots of different obstacles
um or objections that present themselves
but the hypothetical there's lots of
ways of phrasing this which is like
you've probably heard the unicorn
clothes you probably heard like if this
were perfect would you do it i on a
scale from one to ten where would this
program be if 10 was amazing and one was
terrible what you know where is this
they say a number and you say cool what
would make it a 10 why isn't a one like
you guys heard this scripting before so
you guys are like no please talk slower
um
the reason i said we have to learn the
principles behind it rather than
memorizing the script is that it all is
based on one thing which is hypothetical
which is if this were perfect would you
do it because you get a hypothetical
agreement
and they say yes if it were the thing is
if you're like if this were perfect
would you do it if someone says no then
you're like girl okay
like let's take five steps back
does my breath smell
yeah
because the thing is they've actually
told you a lot there it's like it has
nothing to do with the stuff you're
talking about they don't trust you and
now we can talk about that right so it's
a great question to frame like where are
we and so it's like if this were perfect
would you do it sometimes they'll laugh
if you ever pour the left they'll say
yes right and so then you get to flip it
and say
then what's different between perfect
and what we've got the thing is is that
people are very hard they don't actually
know how to generate making a program
because they're not going to like know
all the things you can deliver on the
spot right
and so they're like
most of the time they'll be like
i don't know
you're like right well because it sounds
like it's nothing to the program it's
all about to do with you so let's talk
about that
right and all of a sudden boom
one step closer to the truth does that
make sense yeah yeah all right
and that's why we do hypotheticals so if
it were perfect what's missing and then
if you can if it's if they do give you
an answer and they're like i just don't
want to do broccoli
and you're like
i'd do green beans would you do it
they're like yeah you're like great
green means it is sign here right like
something you would be [ __ ] amazed
how many times [ __ ] like that happened
so it's like one crazy thing it's like
well if we didn't have that would you do
it like oh yeah sure
where were you 10 minutes ago right
and that's how you do hypothetical okay
we're making we're making progress still
with me still digging okay cool
authority all right this is one of my
favorite
fake and so this one instead of having
three i really just have like one very
good
statement of reasoning that you should
understand okay this is real [ __ ] so
this is more of a process than it is
anything else
but
the spouse or decision maker is not
there right now note for you guys a lot
of you guys have had the opportunity to
go talk to a spouse but a lot of you
guys don't have that in your business
right like spouse ain't there and they
leave they're not coming back right
where they are but very small percentage
don't wait for it okay so
what we have to do is try and sidestep
it by isolating the objection and
casting aside the partner because the
partner's not there so how could they
object to anything they don't even
[ __ ] know who you are right and so
the idea is and again this is assuming
if you have a really long term thing
then you want the partner to be there
right like ideally that's what you have
but if you don't have the opportunity
then you got to go through the next step
all right which is
what do you think they wouldn't like and
then they will tell you and then you
just overcome the thing which has
nothing to do with the spouse because
spouse isn't there
right
very easy side step does that make sense
this works really well
it's like why wouldn't they what's like
cause they don't want me to fail whoa
they don't want you to fail
let's talk about you
and so this is the process that i walk
through
do they approve of your current struggle
they happy that you're struggling
no
okay
then why would they not approve of
something
that's going to fix something they
already don't approve of
right they're not happy with how you're
currently doing why would they be
against something that's already making
them unhappy right
right
well let me ask you this and their paws
like if the rules were reversed
and your husband
needed this
to make what he wants his dreams happen
or your wife needed this program to make
her dreams happen
would you support her
then why wouldn't you support you
right
right
and i think the real problem that we're
dealing with here and this is the kicker
is for everybody is that you're asking
for permission instead of support
because it is your life not theirs and
what happens is if you give that power
to them
and then two years from now you're still
fat you're still poor
whatever it is
who are you going to blame
them
and so that's when you have a resentful
marriage because you didn't own your
[ __ ] and so i'm not saying
you shouldn't like explain the decision
to them
but the way you explain to them is what
i just said which is if i don't do this
for me
i'm going to end up resenting you
and i don't want that
and instead of me bitching to you every
day about how we don't have money or
about how i don't like my body
i'm now doing this and i'm joining a
group of support of community of people
just like me and crazy enough
for some reason doctors go to college
right
right that makes sense they go to
medical school lawyers go to law school
but where do entrepreneurs go there's no
entrepreneur school
no one teaches the stuff but it turns
out there are people who teach it just
for this specific industry and i can
take failures of a thousand people and
pack it into a year
and
it's one-tenth the price of a four-year
degree
right and so instead of whining to you
what i commit to is i'm gonna show up
and be a better husband a better wife a
better partner i'm not gonna [ __ ] to
you about the stuff because i'm gonna
take this seriously i'm gonna go all in
and i'm not asking you permission i'm
just asking for your support all right
that's how you can overcome it because
i'm be real with you
it is about them and you have to believe
that like you can't say this unless you
believe it because like you will
you save marriages
by showing people that they're the ones
in control because if they keep saying
my husband's not gonna let me buy a
weight loss program what do you think
she's secretly saying i can't believe
you won't let me do it
right if that's real if she's using it
as a foil you side said be good to self
right
but that might be the real thing and if
that is the thing then you have to let
them step into that
and that's where you know
having that's where like having a
three-day no-sweat guarantee or
something like that is also helpful it's
like hey sign up and i use i use a lot
of rapport and humor in my selling and
so i'd be like hey
cindy
if you sign up
and you tell your husband and he's upset
you have and when he sees you he's like
girl i don't want you to get in shape i
want you to stay overweight i want you
to put those sweatpants on i want you
sit on that couch reach your hand a bag
of cheetos put the the cheetos fingers
on there
i want you to create generational
unhealth i want you to live 10 years
less long i want you to see our
grandkids i don't want that right i want
to marry a younger better you sooner
because you're going to have a heart
attack if he says that to you you have
him calm and then they're like cracking
up and you're like okay okay listen sign
up three day no sweat like if he if he
does tell you that he just wants you to
be out of shape and never leave him
because uh because he's once you get too
hot because he's insecure if he says
that
um yeah just let me know all right
so like the whole time you're just
joking and stuff but the three-day
guarantee helps like nudge a lot of
these people over is that cool you guys
get that one
okay
sweet
and so that goes for you right like it's
it's about support not permission that's
the bottom line right support not
permission because otherwise you're
going to blame them for your lack of
dreams being realized rather than
blaming the person it should which is
you all right so this is avoidance now
we're getting to the core
we've gotten rid of time we know that
you've got time and the best time to do
it is today
because
you're going to be busy forever right
value we know that you can't afford it
if you can't afford it you'll buy it if
you can't afford it's a great reason to
do it and if the value is there
then there's no reason not to because
it'll pay for itself
right what's money good for anyways
you're gonna pay for the program
regardless you wanna pay less time or
more time
value's not a problem
fit you got to step into an identity
right you've got to be willing to change
and the question is just whether the
pain that you're experiencing
is less than the pain of the change that
takes to experience the next thing
right if they step into that they're
good because it's not about resources
it's about resourcefulness so fit's not
an issue
authority they have to own it it's about
support not permission we all here
do you feel like we've peeled the layers
back on your prospects
and they're just laid bare naked there
just
you've solicited the sale
now you got to close all right
avoidance so now they're like wait what
do you think about
it so
now that we've exhausted i'm putting
this as emphasis we've exhausted all
outside reasons
now we're finally talking to someone in
power and that is what a good coach does
we don't make decisions for people we
help them make decisions so here's i
have to think about it not sure give me
a hand who's dealt with somebody who
says things that way all right at least
one person here i'm kidding all you guys
did you guys are great
so this is how i divide this up
past present future and so hopefully
this should already before i dive into
these give you simple frameworks to work
through time you've got macro micro when
then right you've got you got value
you're thinking about it's not a lot of
money even if it were a lot of money
it's not a lot of money you're going to
pay for it either way but you have the
simple frameworks that you can walk
through you might just hit them with one
and if they hit it with again give them
the other angle because they're logical
frameworks they're not scripts that's
why i made them bubbles you don't have
to memorize it just gotta understand it
past
so like i need to think about it
and so the thing is and this the first
bubble there is if someone's like i feel
like this is happening so fast can we
get that one like i just i just got on
the phone with you i don't really know
who you are and you're like hey this is
not a fast decision right you've been
making this decision for last six years
you continually make the decision all
we're doing to say is deciding you're
actually going to do something about it
right how long you want to lose weight a
long time
so this is not a fast decision at all
but the thing is is that
and this is where you go sunk cost
so if i were talking to you guys i would
say
you find you know you bought tickets
because you saw some ad
you registered there you got your
flights you got a hotel you blocked the
time you flew here
you listened to this whole thing
you're six inches from gold
this isn't a fast decision at all you
did all these things to get here because
it's important to you so don't let that
distortion
stop you from getting what you want
right it's fear
right let's face that what are you
afraid of having happen which by the way
i took the slide out but my two favorite
questions to ask in a in a sale that i
feel like are the fastest to cut through
is what are you most afraid of having
happen if you buy
what are you most afraid of
what's the worst thing that you envision
in your mind and if they're not sure i
just fill in the bikes i'm like i take
your credit card i swipe over as much as
i possibly can i go to vegas i put it
all on black and then i go to monaco
where they can't extradite me fair
enough and they're like i was not
thinking that and you're like right
so what's the worst you know like what's
what's the real thing
like and then they're like you know
i just have bought so many programs
before you're like right
let's talk about that right and so i'm
gonna skip one forward and then i'm
gonna go back to it this is one of my
favorite obstacle or objection overcomes
it's i call don't let it burn you twice
and this literally you can see the date
it happened yesterday this girl texted
me or messed april 6th she said it's
crazy to think that i had a sales call
with you six years ago and i'm kicking
myself in the butt for not jumping on
this is yesterday
right like i don't even know the company
anymore and i said you let a bad
decision burn you twice once when you
made your poor investment but a second
time when you let that bad investment
stop you from a good investment it would
be like anybody ever have a boyfriend or
girlfriend in middle school or high
school that they're not currently
married to
anyone just like just come on
help me out here okay
it would be like having a bad eighth
grade boyfriend or girlfriend and being
like you know what
men aren't for me
all coaches suck
right
there's good coaches there's bad coaches
there's crazy ass [ __ ] and there's
crazy ass dudes you know what i mean
like there's also good ones and some
things if you stop if you let the bad
one prevent you from the good one you
get burned by being with the bad one and
because you let the bad one control your
next decision
right
and so when someone has had a bad
experience with doing keto or whatever
the [ __ ] right or you had a bad
experience with some program that you
did or did not do or they didn't fulfill
whatever
either way
don't let that burn you twice because no
matter what you're gonna have to do
you're gonna have to do these actions
whether you're part of the program or
not
you gotta do these workouts where you're
part of the program or not it doesn't
matter you're gonna have to do it so you
might as well do it but somebody can get
you there faster right
let me go back one real quick so
it's not a fast decision and this is
another one that i love which is
do you think that you're maybe in this
position because you have struggled to
make a decision in the past you have
waffled when it came time to make to
make the hard call have you been in this
conversation and said no before
yeah
do you think that's why you're here
yeah
do you think that might be the reason
you should change that
yeah
okay let's change it one decision change
your life
and the last one is like
are you tired of another year of almost
right tied another year of almost
hitting your goals of almost getting to
10k a month of of almost you know hiring
the team that you wanted of almost
retiring your your wife or husband or
almost moving into the neighborhood that
you wanted to move into or almost being
able to pay for your kids recreational
sports rather than not being able to
because you can't afford it
you're tired of another year of almost
well if you're tired of another you're
almost and we can't do what we're doing
to get here for another year
because we're gonna get another year
almost and so the question isn't what it
costs you but how much has it cost you
to not decide up to this point
right the cost of inaction
and i think that when we think about our
lives in reverse
we never regret the things that we did
we regret the things we didn't do
the opportunities that we let pass by
and i think that if you can let that
person step into that power they will
make the decision to help themselves
like this person did not
all right present
so depends on what you're talking to
someone's talking about past stuff then
you deal with the past stuff the second
frame for avoidance is present which is
they just don't know how to make a
[ __ ] decision right and so you have
to help them make a decision and so this
one the rocking chair is one that i just
for some reason have used a tremendous
amount of time especially when i'm
selling weight loss is to be like i just
really really need to think about it
like totally understand
well let's walk through like what that
looks like you're not gonna like go home
sit in the rocking chair you know smoke
a cigarette because of course you're not
healthy yet right you'll quit when
you're healthy right you're smoking your
cigarette you're like hmm am i gonna do
this weight loss program right you just
sit there and stare into the clouds like
i wonder no of course you get in your
car and then you're gonna realize you
got to pick up timmy from soccer
practice you got to get groceries you
got to cook you got to clean you got to
pick up you know go do laundry gotta do
all these things right and then three
four five days from now you're gonna put
on that old pair of jeans and it's not
gonna fit and you're like [ __ ]
and just there
you'll have made the decision you'll
keep living your life
and so let's just make it now because
the reality is that it doesn't take
information to make decisions so it
doesn't take time to make decisions it
takes information
and i'm the only source of information
you got
so let's talk
i'm here i'm here for you let's do it
right because that's the fallacy is that
people think they need more time to make
decisions because they assume they will
get more information in that time
but if you are the source of the
information
then time does not help them
and so let's confront it now and let me
answer the questions you have to make
the decision one way or another does
that make sense
all right
and so then they're like well then [ __ ]
how do i make a decision you're like
glad you asked
so there's three things that we got to
understand
do you believe that this product or
service is going to help you achieve
what you want
yes or no
they're going to say yes right if they
don't you can confront it note all of
these
are confronting decisions so we've moved
all the way down the onion right we're
at truth now and all like the theme of
the of the last bullet is confrontation
we have to confront the decision we got
to peel it back and be like are we going
to do this or not right because we
already got out the time we got out the
fit we got out the sp we got everything
out of the way it's just you do you
think that this is going to help you get
closer to your goals yes or no
two
do you trust me to fill to fulfill my
word that i said i'm going to help you
i'm going to do these calls i'm going to
do these workouts i'm going to do
whatever right
three this is the mo probably the most
important one
do you think it'll work for you
and if they say no you say why not
and then they have to defend why not
and then it's very easy at that point
it's a six inch putt all right and once
they say yes to all three which is
usually what will happen they're like
cool we'll make the decision together
you know how to make the decision
they'll say no you go through the three
the last question is they said yes yes
yes it's just
do you have or have access to the amount
of money to get started
do you have the amex do i want to help
you enroll in an mx cause i wanna i
wanna help you
i'm good either way
but if you believe that this is going to
help you get closer you believe that
what i'm saying is true and you believe
that you can be successful it's my moral
obligation to get you going and do
everything in my power to help you get
the money or get access to it because
the real world is if i was giving you a
ferrari right now for five thousand
dollars you'd find the money if your
landlord needed you to come up with ten
thousand dollars because you had
background in payroll you'd find the
money so find the money let's do it
right
three
who wants to make informed decisions
yes
how can you make an informed decision
if you haven't even tried it
huh so this is when you have some
element of trial in the program or some
sort of guarantee which is why i'm a big
fan of guarantees
it's like well
you can't make the decision to buy
that's informed until you're on the
inside so i'm not even asking you to
make a decision right now i'm just
actually making an informed decision
which you can only do on the inside and
if after 30 days i'm not what i said
this product doesn't do what i told you
i didn't fulfill my promise and you
don't think it's gonna work for you you
let me know i'll give you the money back
low pressure you get someone to decide
but not deciding
even easier that make sense
think that'll help you close
yeah
all right
and then uh this one is i it depends on
who you're selling to but sometimes if
you have a logical person it's like do
you know what deciding even means
like where the etymology of the work
comes from it's d cadere which is latin
which means to cut off
to kill off and so the question is
which future are we killing off today
are we killing off the future of the
dreams that you want
are we killing off the future
sorry are we killing off the future
of
of not doing anything and the life that
you've lived up to this point
because indecision is a decision
inaction is an active decision right
and so it's just which one are we
killing today we kill your dreams we
clean your past
second last one
future so we talked about past so if
they're thinking about the past things
that hurt them don't burn you twice etc
right they don't know how to make a
decision rocking chair this is how you
make a decision three things you've
accessed the money great let's get going
you want to kill your past you want to
kill your future right awesome we're
talking about the future this is
actually magnifying pain
which is
cool you got here it's been five years
you've been struggling
how's another five years sound
what if we just keep doing let's go with
indecision let's look at it what is five
years of you doing what you've been
doing look like
and is that a place you want to be
no
you got to change the change let's do it
right
and then you go right into let's
consider the options which is like
like this is logic right so let's
consider the options
option one
you do the thing
you get the result
life is awesome
option two
you don't do the thing you don't get the
result because you didn't do the thing
option three you do the thing but then
you don't get the result
all these are the options that can
happen in front of you
because we have a guarantee
they're all risk-free except for one of
them
only one of them has a true guarantee of
not getting you where you want which is
walking out the door
so which risk-free option you want the
one that's risk-free that guarantees
that you're not going to get there or
the one that's risk-free and has the
potential to get you where you want to
go
right
that's not an emotional close it's logic
and if you have an offer that's set up
that way you should be able to close
most people as long as they don't think
you're an [ __ ]
right
okay
this is one that's more around urgency
because again this is avoidance
if someone says
i'm still not sure i want to think about
it more or whatever you say well you're
not going to struggle forever right
like you don't want to struggle forever
you're going to do something about this
whether it's weight loss business
whatever they're going to say yes
you're like well if you're going to fix
your business eventually
you might as well start fixing it now so
you can start enjoying the fruits of
that labor sooner would you prefer
making more money faster or slower
what's your preference great so if
you're going to do it eventually you
might as well do it now
so it makes sense it's a little nudge
this is a final one that i just really
like from a framing perspective which is
instead of like
this has to be my savior this program
has to get me to an ifbb pro bikini body
and i'm 100 pounds overweight
probably not realistic right
reframing the question is
do you think that making the decision is
going to be help you get closer or
further from your goal that's it because
if we keep making decisions that keep
getting us closer we will get there
eventually but if we make decisions that
get us further away we will not get
there and so do you think that this is
going to get you closer to your goal
than what you're currently doing yes
what are we waiting for we don't need to
be snipers we need to be directionally
right we do that long enough we'll get
there does that make sense
that helps you too because we have this
fear of perfectionism is this gonna be
the one
probably not
but it will get you [ __ ] way closer
right so i can tell you there's no one
program that changed my life
but the decision to buy education
changed my life forever
does that make sense
all right
boom and so let me look at the top we
have no reasons left
not to own the power that you have
it's just you
all right and here's bonus number six
and you can use this as one of like
there's some clothes that you use all
the time you always go back to right
the reason you are telling yourself not
to do this is the reason you do it
how long do you want i can't afford this
to be on your list of problems in life
the fact that you don't have time is the
very reason you need to do this
the fact that you're so dependent on
your spouse is the reason you need to
take this decision and own it
right
the fact that you're not sure about the
person that you want to be is the very
reason that we're going to help you get
it in this program so whatever the
reason is is usually the biggest
chain that you're holding on to is the
thing that you're enslaving yourself to
is the thing that you're casting your
power to
if you break that chain power comes back
to you
and so the very reason that you're
holding yourself back is typically the
very reason that you need to do it so
hopefully this helps you realize that
you and your clients are always in
complete power did i accomplish that
awesome
thank you
and like i promised at the beginning my
hope is that you become more powerful by
making decisions rather than letting
life make them for you all right so
here's a few final thoughts
fortunes are created by taking a lot of
risk with a little bit of money
fortunes are maintained by taking a
little bit of risk with a lot of money
and every one of those people that was
self-made
takes a lot of risk a little bit of
money and sometimes you need to take
that step because it's the only way to
build the fortune all right and if
everything that i've ever made in my
life
sorry everything that i've made in my
life is the result of investing in my
own education it has gotten me far
higher returns than any stock any real
estate any crypto right any whatever by
a mile
and people say like it's all about
investing yourself like i just i think
it sounds amorphous it's like buy
experience and skills
because no government can take that from
you no divorce can take that from you
nothing can take that from you and i
come from a family where so we're
persian and so my my parents had to flee
iran during the revolution
and so
they had land and houses and other stuff
right
and my uncle
was
uh the brother to a guy who started the
lottery in iran he owned the lottery
because you can do that there right
very rich
and so my dad and him he went to london
my dad went to the u.s
he had no skills
and he was able to just forge enough
money to buy a print shop and he lives
above the print shop in london and still
to this day that's what he does and went
to visit him
it was incredibly sad seeing just like
what once once a incred and his wife my
dad gave her a scarf and it was like a
nice scarf apparently and she just
bawled she's like i used to have rooms
of these and now i have nothing and blah
blah blah right my dad came the united
states with a thousand dollars
but because he had skills he built it
all from scratch
and so i mean he was a doctor as all
middle eastern and indians are um
right doctor lawyer account engineer
anyways uh the only four approved paths
but when we say invest in that
we come from a place where like it was
literally all taken
the government was like that's our house
now that's our land now that bank
account is our bank account now
and so that was why it was so and like
that might be a benefit for me i had
somebody who's always like it's the only
thing no one can take from you
and so why would you not invest in the
one thing that can never be stolen can
never be taken and compounds with time
and it increases your capacity
to make money increases your capacity to
live
and so i like to think of the
investments that i've made in myself as
bricks on a bridge
and so if i'm on the bottom left here
and where i want to be is the top right
ish right looking like the nightmare
before christmas now
you're going like
there are many skills that it takes to
cross the bridge right and just like you
have an arithmetic teacher in high
school once you learn calculus you're
not like that guy was a load of [ __ ]
calculus is what no you have to learn
things in sequence right
and so the thing is is that we build
this bridge it's one brick at a time and
i always come back to the same question
which is is this going to get me closer
to where i want to go
i don't need it to get me there
i just need to get closer and if i get
better i'll get there eventually right
as long as i don't stop moving
and so that's why that's that what i've
dedicated my life to education
my mission is to document and share the
best practice of building world-class
companies
because when you realize that you are
the source
you realize that superman is not coming
it's just you
and every decision that you make is a
vote towards or against the person that
we want to be
and so the question for you is that are
your decisions voting towards the person
that you want to become or just more of
what you already have
and so people ask me all the time how do
you move so quickly and the answer is i
know how to buy time
and the follow-up question is how do you
buy time you buy time by buying the time
took other people to make mistakes that
taught them the lessons that's how you
do it right that's that's the heck
and so right now the ignorance of not
knowing how to create a million dollars
a year
is costing you a million dollars a year
the fact that you don't know how to make
a million dollars a year is costing you
a million dollars a year think about it
right
and so therefore you should always be
willing to invest money to increase the
capacity for your income
because once you have it that capacity
pays you forever
you're increasing your ability does that
make sense we're widening the pipe
and so when i thought about this i just
added zeros to it and i was like it's
[ __ ] costing me a billion dollars a
year not knowing how to make a billion
dollars god
right
but it's true because the thing the
number one tax that no one appreciates
or no one respects is not the tax of the
government it's not capital gains it's
not income tax it's the time tax of
ignorance
someone asked layla yesterday what's the
number one thing that people from 0 to
10k
are messing up
you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
doing
that's what's messing you up you're
ignorant you have no idea you're eating
an orange like an apple no clue right
and it's not because you don't have the
processing power it's not because you
don't have the ability to reason
it's because you just don't know
and so the goal is to pay down
the time tax of ignorance as fast as
humanly possible and the only way you do
that is by educating and investing
yourself
right
specifically investing in experiences
that build skills so
make the decisions that to help yourself
implement like crazy
take ownership because we just
discovered that all the other [ __ ] is
not real it is literally a distortion of
reality that anything that you give your
power to that's not you
is fake
you're making it a false god in your
life and your prospects are too and now
you know how to confront those when your
mind tries to play tricks on you
and realize that there are no silver
bullets
no program is going to save your life
all right but some things can move you
close to your goals
and when those rare opportunities
present themselves
take them
all right because either you win or you
learn and both of those get you closer
to wherever you want to go all right and
so
i'll wrap up with this ten years ago i
had to
that was me in a swanky uh you know when
i was a consultant looking cool
it was actually after i don't even have
a good picture when i was a consultant
but there's me in a suit um
and i i knew i hated the job that i had
um i made okay money but i just like i
just really wasn't happy um
and
i emailed 40 gym owners i was like hey i
think i want to get in fitness can
somebody like help me out
one guy was like sure you can work for
free i was like awesome uh that guy was
saying back to your
and anybody know who sam bacteria is
ray's hand
geez okay well seven-figure sam is what
he used to be known as he actually died
during covet
which was really sad for me because i
really looked up to sam
and the thing is is that
when i got to his office
i literally drove across the country
from baltimore to l.a or chino hills
which is where he was and i showed up
without notice and he was like you're a
psychopath i just met you from the
internet i was like i'm here i'm ready
to learn he was like i'm going to lunch
and um
but right after he came back from lunch
he was like
all right so you should join my my
mastermind and i was like i don't have a
gym
he's like that's okay
it was a gym mastermind
um
and i didn't i mean like i was 22 like i
did not have a lot of money um
and he was like well it's 10 grand
and i was like i
i don't know and he's like you need to
[ __ ] commit man he's like you've been
waffling back and forth i had multiple
phone calls with him before i left
um he's like i think you need to draw a
line in the sand
and thank you god you know thank god he
did
because i did take a step over i had no
idea what the [ __ ] i was doing but i was
trying to start paying down the time tax
of ignorance and i got around a whole
bunch of other fitness professionals and
i learned way more from all of them than
i ever learned from sam
but because of that my belief started to
change the ways i saw the world change
the traits i started to embody change
and started taking steps the mastermind
i got from sam is not what made me a
hundred million dollars
but it got me on the right path towards
making it and so if you can make those
choices i think it's these small steps
not believing that it's going to be a
savior but believing that it's aligned
with where you want to go and believing
in yourself that if you keep walking on
this path you'll get there so thank you
guys so much
[Applause]